100 Trump ist gerade Gerichtsgebäude
angekommen die Wagenkolonne vor Ende
Tiefgarage unter dem Bundesgericht hier
in dantan miamia Hunderte Trump Anhänger
haben die Fahrt verfolgt sie haben den
Präsidenten zugejubelt zugerufen die
ganze Wagenkolonne war ungefähr 12 Wagen
natürlich angeführt von den Agenten des
Secret Service die hier kurz auf den
Wagen ausgestiegen sind versucht haben
diese Situation hier zu beobachten sie
schienen leicht nervös wenn die
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen sind hier nicht
besonders groß aber es sind die einfach
nur gelbe Polizei Absperrbänder
aufgehängt worden keine Barrieren oder
ähnliches die Polizei hier in Miami
möchte hier eine eine weichere Taktik an
den Tag legen jedenfalls Donald Trump zu
seiner Anklage Vorlesung angekommen hier
am Gerichtsgebäude und es warten die
schwersten Stunden seines Lebens auf ihn